one of the more stressful pieces is the
in-between time when you don't really
know who you're fighting when you're
fighting what what type of matchup
they're going to give you it is and it's
like super stressful and it's like
that's like a thing to deal with in its
own but I also feel like I'm at a very
good point in my skills where I I feel
super comfortable taking any challenge
at this point with where I am yeah so
um at this point it's like okay before
it was like hey let's take this fight at
this time let's take this fight at this
point it's like no like I'm ready to be
champ and I actually feel like I mean
that as far as like where my skills are
where my head is yes where my spirit is
that that's where I am now so at this
point it's like yeah whatever challenge
so I don't really I'm not stressing too
much about like who am I getting next
but I almost am certain it's going to be
for a number one Contender spot it would
have to be